after two weeks of apocalyptic scenes
fires in greece still burning an
environmental and economic reckoning on
a national scale now begins
during the early days of the crisis a
mayor in the attica basin in north
athens described the devastation from
fires as incalculable
greece's prime minister has since
promised to put things back the way they
were
i'm really sorry to break the bad news
but this is our life from now on and we
still have to do everything possible
because if it gets worse this is going
to get completely out of control um the
united nations are mentioning an
extension point for humanity if we reach
a certain point of temperature rise so
it's dangerous it's complicated it's not
going to go back to whatever normal we
thought we had
some decades ago
this is the new normal but we still have
a lot of things to do on the prevention
adaptation and mitigation of the issue
fire damage property loss entire
communities displaced serious immediate
effects but in the long run this will be
the new normal increasingly intense
summer wildfires it spells disaster for
the country's vital tourism sector just
starting to recover from the coronavirus
pandemic the effects of the wildfires on
evia are being felt all over the island
as well as on the mainland once pristine
beaches were for weeks surrounded by
smoke clouds and falling ash and now
those beaches are visibly polluted
on social media visitors post videos of
beaches covered in silt and debris from
the fires on the island one person said
the water tastes of charcoal it's a very
sad situation it's a very bad situation
a hotel operator on evia island said the
fires have kept tourists away and
decimated small businesses that relied
on the forest before we had the covered
we had a slowdown in our work now
usually uh in 15 of august which is a
big fed from for greece
usually we had hundred percent
full the hotels were full in hundred
percent
now we have zero percent access to the
island has also been limited to
firefighters and essential personnel
only also bad for business
environmental experts say world leaders
knew better and failed to take action
that the scientific community has been
screaming about climate change for years
for the global ecosystem there is no
going back climate threat is now a cost
of doing business that is here to stay
zane basravi al-jazeera on greece evia
island